YUFEI ZHAO: So
today we are going
to start a new chapter
on graph limits.
So graph limits is a relatively
new subject in graph theory.
So as the name
suggests, we're looking
at some kind of an analytic
limit of graphs, which
sounds kind of
like a strange idea
because you think of graphs as
fundamentally discrete objects.
But let me begin with
an example to motivate,
at least pure mathematical
motivation for graph limits.
There are several other ways
you can motivate graphs limits,
especially coming from
more applied perspectives.
But let me stick with
the following story.
So suppose you lived
in ancient Greece
and you only knew
rational numbers.
You didn't know
about real numbers.
But you understand
perfectly rational numbers.
And we wish to maximize.
So we wish to then minimize
the following polynomial,
x cubed minus x, let's
say for x between 0 and 1.
So you can do this.
And suppose also the
Greeks knew calculus
and take the derivative
and all of that.
So you find that.
You have a problem
because we know--
so given our advanced
state of mathematics,
we know that the maximum--
so the minimizer is at x
equals to 1 over root 3.
But that number doesn't
exist in the real numbers.
So how might a civilization
that only knew rational numbers
express this answer?
They could say, the minimum
occurs not in Q. So there's
not minimized in Q--
but not minimized by a single
number, but by a sequence.
And this is a sequence that
a more advanced civilization
would know, a sequence that
converges to 1 over root of 3.
But I can give you this sequence
through some other means.
And this is one of the ways
of defining the complete set
of real numbers, for instance.
But you can define explicitly
a sequence of real numbers
that converges.
But of course, this is
all quite cumbersome
if you have to
actually write down
this sequence of real numbers
to express this answer.
It will be much better if
we knew the real numbers.
And we do.
And the real numbers,
in some sense,
in the very rigorous
sense, is a completion
of the rational numbers.
That's the story that
we're all familiar with.
But now let's think
about graphs which
are some kind of a
discrete set of objects,
akin to the rational numbers.
And the story now
is, among graphs,
suppose I have a fixed
p between 0 and 1.
And the problem
now is to minimize
the 4-cycle density among graphs
with density, with edge density
p.
So this is some kind of
optimization problem.
So I don't restrict
the number of vertices.
You can use as many
vertices as you like.
And I would like to minimize
the 4-cycle density.
Now, we saw a few lectures
ago this inequality
that tells us that--
so we saw a few lectures ago
that this density is always
at least p to the fourth.
So in the lecture on
quasirandomness, so
we saw this inequality.
And we also saw
that this minimum
is approached by a sequence
of quasirandom graphs.
And in some sense, that-- so
the answer is p to the fourth.
And there's not
a specific graph.
There's no one graph
that minimizes.
This 4-cycle density is
minimized by a sequence.
And just like in the story
with the rational numbers
and the real numbers,
it would be nice
if we didn't have to
write out the answer
in this cumbersome,
sequential way,
but just have a single
graphical-like object that
depicts what the
minimizer should be.
And graph limits provides a
language for us to do this.
So one of the goals
of the graph limits--
this gives us a single
object for this minimizer
instead of taking a sequence.
So roughly that is the idea that
you have a sequence of graphs.
And I would like
some analytic object
to capture the behavior of
the sequence in the limit.
And these graph limits
can be written actually
in a fairly concrete form.
And so now let me begin
with some definitions.
The main object
that we'll look at
is something called a graphon.
So it merges the two
words graph, function.
A graphon is by definition a
symmetric, measurable function,
often denoted by the letter
W from the unit squared
to the 0, 1 interval.
And here being symmetric means
that if you exchange the two
argument variables, this
function remains the same.
So that's it.
So that's the
definition of a graphon.
And these are the objects that
will play the role of limits
for sequences of graphs.
And I will give you lots
of examples in a second.
So that's the definition.
This is the form of
the graphons that we'll
be looking at mostly.
But just to mention
a few remarks,
that the domain can
be instead any product
of any square of a
probability measure space--
so instead of taking
the 0, 1 interval,
I could also use any
probability measure space.
So it's only slightly
more general.
So there are some general
theorems in measure theory
that tells us that most
probability measure
spaces, if they're
nice enough, they
are in some sense
equivalent or can
be captured by this interval.
So I don't want you to worry
too much about all the measure
where there are technicalities.
I think they are not so
important for the discussion
of graph limits.
But there are some subtle issues
like that just lurking behind.
But I just don't want to
really talk about them.
So for the most part,
we'll be looking
at graphons of this one.
And also the-- so instead of
the domain, so the values--
so instead of 0, 1
interval, you could also
take a more general space,
for example, the real numbers
or even the complex numbers.
I'm going to use
the word graphon
to reserve this word for when
the values are between 0 and 1.
And if it's in R, let me
call this just a kernel,
although that will
not come up so much.
So when I say
graphon, I just mean
the values between 0 and 1.
Although if you do look up
papers in the literature,
sometimes they don't use
these words so consistently.
So be careful what
they mean by a graphon.
So that's the definition.
But now let me give
you some examples
on how do we think of
graphons and what do they
have to do with graphs.
So if we start with a
graph, I want to show you
how to turn it into a graphon.
So let's start with this graph,
which you've seen before.
This is the half graph.
So from this graph, I
can label the vertices
and form an adjacency
matrix of this graph, where
I label the rows and
columns by the vertices
and put in zeros
and ones according
to whether the
edges are adjacent.
So that's the adjacency matrix.
And now I want you
to view this matrix
as a black and white picture.
So think one of these
pixelated images, where I
turn the ones into black boxes.
Of course, on the blackboard,
black is white and white
is black.
So I turn the ones
into black boxes.
And I leave the zeros
as empty white space.
So I get this image.
And I think of this
image as a function.
And this is the function
going from 0, 1, squared to 0,
1, interval, taking
only 0 and 1 values.
So that's a function
on the square.
But now, so this
is a single graph.
So for any specific
graph, I can turn it
into a graphon like this.
But now imagine you have
a sequence of graphs.
And in particular, consider
a sequence of half graphs.
So here is H3.
So Hn is the general half graph.
And you can imagine
that, as n gets large,
this picture looks like--
instead of the
staircase you just
have a straight line
connecting the two ends.
And indeed, this function
here, this graphon,
is the limit of the
sequence of half graphs
as n goes to infinity.
So one way you can
think about graphons
is you have a
sequence of graphs.
You look at their
adjacency matrix.
You view it as a picture,
a pixelated image,
black and white according
to the zeros and ones
in its adjacency matrix.
And as you take a sequence,
you make your eyes a little bit
blurry.
And then you think about
what the sequence of images
converges to.
So the resulting
limit is the limit
of this sequence of graphs.
So that's an
informal explanation.
So I haven't done
anything precisely.
And in fact, one
needs to be somewhat
careful with this
depiction because let
me give you another example.
Suppose I have a sequence of
random or quasirandom graphs
with edge density 1/2.
So what does this look like?
And I have this picture here.
And I have a lot of--
so I have a lot of--
one-half of the
pixels are black.
And the other half
pixels are white.
And you can think,
from far away,
I cannot distinguish necessarily
which ones are black and which
ones are white.
And in the limit, it looks
like a grayscale image,
with a grayscale being
one-half density.
And indeed, it converges to
the constant function, 1/2.
So the limits represented
by this problem up here
is the constant graphon
with the constant value p.
But now let me give you
a different example.
Consider a checkerboard.
So here is a checkerboard, where
I color the squares according
to, in this alternating
black and white manner,
according to a
usual checkerboard.
And as the number of
squares goes to infinity,
what should this converge to?
By the story I
just told you, you
might think that
if you zoom out,
everything looks density 1/2.
And so you might guess
that the image, the limit,
is the 1/2 constant.
But what is this graph?
It's a complete bipartite graph.
It is a complete bipartite
graph between all the even rows.
And there's a different way
to draw the complete bipartite
graph--
namely, that picture, just by
permuting the rows and columns.
And it's much more
reasonable that this
is the limit of the sequence
of complete bipartite
graphs with equal parts.
So one needs to be very careful.
And so it's not necessarily
an intuitive definition.
The idea that you
just squint your eyes
and think about what
the image becomes,
that works fine for
intuition for some examples,
but not for others.
So we do really need
to be careful in giving
a precise definition.
And here the rearrangement
of the rows and columns
needs to be taken care of.
So let me be more precise.
Starting with a graph G, I can--
so let me label the
vertices by 1 through n.
I can denote by W sub G
this function, this graphon,
obtained by the
following procedure.
First, you partition
the interval
into intervals of
length exactly 1 over n.
And you set W of x
comma y to be basically
what happened in
the procedure above.
If x and y lie in the box
I sub I cross I sub J,
then I put in 1 if I is
adjacent to J and 0 otherwise--
so this picture,
where we obtained
by taking the adjacency
matrix and transforming it
into a pixelated image.
What are some of
the things that we
would like to do with graph
limits or graphs in general?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is the range
also 0, 1, squared or 0, 1?
YUFEI ZHAO: Thank you.
The range is 0, 1.
So here are some quantities
we are interested in when
considering graph limits.
So given two graphs, G and H, we
say that a graph homomorphism--
so a graph homomorphism
between from G to H
is a map of their vertexes such
that the edges are preserved.
So you have-- and so
whenever uv is an edge of H,
your image vertices get
mapped to an edge of G.
And we are interested in the
number of graph homomorphisms.
So often I use uppercase to
denote a set of homomorphisms G
to H--
and lowercase to
denote the number.
So for example, the
number of homomorphisms
from a single vertex--
so a single vertex with no edge
to a graph G, that's just the--
what is this quantity?
So some number of
vertices of G--
what about homomorphisms
from an edge to G?
AUDIENCE: The number of edges?
YUFEI ZHAO: Not quite the
number of edges, but twice
the number of edges.
What about the number
of homomorphisms
from a triangle to G?
AUDIENCE: 6 times the
number of triangles.
YUFEI ZHAO: So yeah, you got
the idea-- so the 6 times
the number of triangles.
So now let me ask a slightly
more interesting question.
What about the number
of homomorphisms from H
to a triangle?
What's a different name
for this quantity here?
It's the number of
proper three colorings.
So it's the number of
proper three colorings,
the number of proper
colorings of H with three
labeled colors, red,
green, and blue.
So think about the
three vertices.
That's red, green, and blue.
And whichever vertex
of H can map to red,
color that vertex red.
So you see that there is a
one-to-one correspondence
between such homomorphisms
and proper colorings.
So many important graph
parameters, graph quantities,
can be encoded in terms
of graph homomorphisms.
And these are the
ones that we're
going to be looking
at most of the time.
When we're thinking
about very large graphs,
often it's not the number of
homomorphisms that concern us,
but the density
of homomorphisms.
And the difference
between homomorphisms
on one hand and subgraphs is
that the homomorphisms are not
quite the same as
subgraphs, other
than this multiplicity,
because you might have
non-injective homomorphisms.
But these non-injective
homomorphisms
do not end up contributing
very much because they only
have n to the number of
vertices of H minus 1
on that border where I think
of n as the number of vertices
of G. n is supposed to be large.
So in terms of graph
limits when n gets large,
I don't need to distinguish
so much between homomorphisms
and subgraphs.
We define the homomorphism
density, denoted by the letter
t, from H to G, by--
define it to be the
fraction of all vertex maps
that are homomorphisms.
So this is also equivalent to
be defined as the probability
that a uniform random
map from the vertex set
of H to the vertex set of G
is a homomorphism from H to G.
So it's a graph homomorphism.
And this quantity turns
out to be quite important.
So we're going to be
seeing this a lot.
And because of this remark
over here, in the limit,
this quantity of graph
homomorphism densities
in the limit as the number of
vertices G goes to infinity
and H fixed, the
homomorphism densities
approaches the same limit
as subgraph densities.
So you should regard
these two quantities
as basically the same thing.
Any questions so far?
So all of these quantities
so far defined are for--
so everything is defined so
far for graphs, so what happens
between graphs and graphs.
So what about for graphons?
I'll give you this limit
object, this analytic object.
I can still define
densities by integrals now.
So suppose I start with a
symmetric measurable function.
So tell me, for
example, a graphon.
But I can let my range
be even more generous.
Starting with such a function,
I define the graph homomorphism
density from a fixed graph
H to this graphon or kernel,
more generally, to be the
following integral, where I'm--
before writing
down the full form,
let me first give
you an example.
I think it will be more helpful.
So if I'm looking at a triangle
going to W, what I would like
is the integral that captures
the triangle density.
So this quantity here, if I let
x, y, and z vary over 0 and 1,
0 through 1, independently
and uniformly,
then this quantity here captures
the triangle density in W.
In fact, and I'll state this
more precisely in a second--
if you look at the
translation from graph
to graphon and combine
that translation
with this definition here, you
recover the triangle density.
More generally, for H
instead of a triangle,
the H density in a graphon is
defined to be the integral of--
instead of this
product here, I take
a product corresponding to
the graph structure of H
with one factor
for each edge of H.
And the variables go
over the vertex set of H.
So this is the definition
of homomorphism densities,
not for graphs, but for
symmetric measurable functions,
in particular, for graphons.
And we define it
this way because--
and we use the same symbols
because these two definitions
agree.
If you start with a graph and
look at the H density in G,
then this quantity here
is equal to the H density
in the graphon associated
to the graph G constructed
as we did just now.
So make sure you
understand why this is true
and why we defined the
densities this way.
Any questions so far?
So we've given the definition
of graph homomorphism density.
And we've defined these
objects, these graphons.
And I mentioned even something
about the idea of a limit.
But in what sense can we
have a limit of graphs?
So here is an
important definition
on the convergence of graphs.
So in what sense can we say that
a sequence of graphs converge?
So we say that a sequence
of graphs G sub n--
graphs or graphons, so
these two definitions
are interchangeable for what I'm
about to say regarding limits
for graphons, in
which case I'm going
to denote them by W sub n.
So we say the
sequence is convergent
if the sequence of
subgraph densities--
of course, if you are
looking at graphons,
then you should look at the
graphon, the subgraph density
in--
homomorphism density in
graphons if this sequence
converges as n goes to
infinity for every graph H.
So that's the
definition of what it
means for a sequence
of graphs to converge,
which so far looks actually
quite different from what
we discussed intuitively.
But I will state some
theorems towards the end
of this lecture explaining
what the connections are.
So intuitively
what I said earlier
is that you have a
sequence of graphs
that are convergent if you
have some vague notion of one
image morphing into a
sequence of images morphing
into this final image.
Still hold that
thought in your mind.
But that's not a
rigorous definition yet.
The definition we will
use for convergence
is if all the subgraph--
all the homomorphism densities
were equivalently subgraph
densities, they converge.
So this is the definition.
It's not required.
So this is basically
rigorous as stated.
Just as a remark,
it's not required
that the number of
vertices goes to infinity,
although you really should
think that that is the case.
So just to put it
out there-- so I
can have a sequence
of constant graphs
and they will still
be convergent.
And that's still OK.
But you should
think of the number
of vertices going to infinity.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is F
in the definition?
YUFEI ZHAO: F is H. Thank you.
Any other questions?
So there are some questions
that we'd like to discuss.
And this will occupy
the next few lectures
in terms of proving the
following statements.
One is do you always
have graph limits?
If you have a convergent
sequence of graphs,
do they always approach a limit?
And just because
something is convergent
doesn't mean you can represent
the limit necessarily.
So it turns out
the answer is yes.
It turns out that--
and this makes
it a good theory, a
good, useful theory,
and an easy theory to use,
that there is always a limit
object whenever you
have convergence.
And the other
question is while we
have described intuitively
one notion of convergence
and also defined more
rigorously another definition
of convergence, are these
two notions compatible?
And what does this
even mean, this idea
of image becoming closer
and closer to a final image?
What does that even mean?
So these are some
of the questions
that I would like to address.
So in the next few things
that I would like to discuss,
first, I want to
give you a definition
of a distance between two
graphons or two graphs.
If I give you two graphs,
how similar or dissimilar
are they--
so that we have this metric.
And then we can talk about
convergence in metric spaces.
So let's take a quick break.
So given this notion
of convergence,
I would like to define
the notion of distance
between graphs so that
convergence corresponds
to convergence in
the metric space
sense of distance going to 0.
So how can we define distance?
First, let me tell you
that there's a trivial way.
And so there's a way in which
you look at that definition
and produce a distance out.
And here's what you can do.
I can convert that
definition to a metric
by setting the
distance between two
graphs G and G prime to be the
following quantity, obtained
by--
what would I like to do?
I would like to say the
distance goes to 0 if and only
if the homomorphism
densities, they
are all close to each other.
And so I can sum up all
the homomorphism densities
and look at their differences
between G and G prime.
And I simply enumerate the
list of all possible graphs.
I want to be just slightly more
careful with this definition
here because I want
something which--
so when I write
this, this number
might be infinite for
all pairs G and G prime.
So if I just add a scaling
factor here, then--
and this is some distance.
So this is some distance.
And you see that it matches
the definition up there.
But it's completely useless.
It might as well--
might as well not
have said anything
because it's tautologically the
same as what happened up there.
And if I give you two
graphs, it doesn't really
tell you all that
much information
except to encapsulate
that definition
into a single number.
Great.
So I'm just-- the point of
this is just to tell you
that there is always a trivial
way to define distance.
But we want some more
interesting ways.
So what can we do?
So here is an attempt, which
is that of an edit distance.
So we have seen this before when
we discussed removal lemmas.
The edit distance is
the number of edges
you need to change to go from
one graph to the other graph.
And this seems like a pretty
reasonable thing to do.
And it is an important
quantity for many applications,
but turns out not the right
one for all application.
And here is the reason.
So this is why the
edit distance is--
by edit distance, I
mean 1 over the number
of vertex squared times the
number of edge changes needed.
So there's normalization so
that the distance is always
between 0 and 1.
But this is not a
very good notion
for the following reason.
If I take two copies of the
Erdos-Reyni random graph G, n,
1/2, what do you think is
the edit distance between two
such random graphs?
How many edges?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it roughly
one-half of the number of edges
because there's like
a one-half probably
that won't be there or
not be there [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: So yeah, so
let me try to rephrase
what you are saying.
So suppose I have
this G and G prime
both sitting on top
of the vertex set n.
So if I'm not allowed to
rearrange the vertices,
how many edge changes do I need
to go from one to the other?
I need about 1/2.
So one-half the time, I'm going
to have a wrong edge there.
Now you can make this
number just slightly smaller
by permuting the vertices.
But actually you will
not improve that much.
It is still going to be roughly
that edit distance, which
is quite large.
This is almost as large
as you can possibly get
between two arbitrary graphs.
So if we want to say
that random graphs,
they approach a
limit, a single limit,
then this is not a very
good notion because they are
quite far apart for every n.
So this is the reason why
the more obvious suggestion
of an edit distance might
not be such a great idea.
So what should we use instead?
So we should take
inspiration from what we
discussed in quasirandomness.
You have a question.
AUDIENCE: Is the edit
distance only for two graphs
of the same vertex set?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the question
is, is the edit distance only
for two graphs with
the same vertex set?
Let's say yes.
So we'll see later
on, you can also
compare graphs with
different number of vertices.
So hold onto that thought.
So I would like to come up
with a notion of distance
between graphs that is
inspired by our discussion
of quasirandomness earlier.
So think about the discussion of
quasirandomness or quasirandom
graphs.
In what sense can G be close
to a constant, let's say p?
And so this was the
Chung-Graham-Wilson theorem
that we proved a
few lectures ago.
So in what sense
can G be close to p?
And one of those
definitions was discrepancy.
And discrepancy says that
if the following quantity
is small for all
subsets x and y, which
are subsets of vertices of G--
so you remember, all of
you remember, this part,
the discrepancy hypothesis
for quasirandomness.
And this is a kind
of definition that we
would like to describe
when two graphs are
similar to each other, when they
are close in this discrepancy
sense.
So now, instead of a
graph and a number,
what if now I have two graphs?
I'll give you two
graphs of G and G prime.
And what I would like to
say is that, if for now,
so if they have the
same vertex set,
I want to say that there
are close if I have
that the number of edges
between x and y in G
is very close to
the number of edges
between x and y in G prime.
And I normalize by the
number of vertices squared,
so n this number of vertices.
And I would like to find out
the worst possible scenario, so
overall, x and y subsets
of the vertex set.
If this quantity
is small, then I
would like to say that G and G
prime are close to each other.
So this is inspired by
this discrepancy notion.
Can you see anything wrong
with this definition here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: So
permutations are vertices.
So just like in the checkerboard
example we saw earlier,
you have two graphs.
And if they are
indeed labeled graphs
in the same labeled
vertex set, then this
is the definition more
or less what we used.
I will define it more
precisely in a second.
But if they are
unlabeled vertices,
we need to possibly
optimize permutations
over rearrangements of vertices,
which actually turns out
to be quite subtle.
So I'm going to give precise
definitions in a second.
But this one here, so think
about permuting vertices.
But it's actually a bit
more subtle than that.
So here are some
actual definitions.
I'm going to define this
quantity called a cut norm.
So this chapter is all going to
be somewhat functional analytic
in nature.
So get used to the
analytic language.
So the cut norm of W is defined
to be the following quantity
denoted by this norm with a
box in the subscript, which
is defined to be--
if I look at this W, and
I integrate it over a box,
and I would like to
maximize this quantity here
over choices of
boxes S and T, they
are subsets of the interval
measurable subsets.
So choose your-- so over
all possible choices
of measurable
subsets S and T, if I
integrate W over
S cross T, what is
the furthest I can get from 0?
So this is the
definition of cut norm.
And you can already see that
it has some relations to what
were discussed up there.
But while we're
talking about norms,
let me just mention a
few other norms that
might come up later on when
we discuss graph limits.
So there will be a lot
of norms throughout.
So in particular, the lp norm is
going to play a frequent role.
So lp norm is defined by
looking at the peak norm
of the absolute value,
integrated and then
raised to 1 over p.
And so the infinity norm--
so this is almost, but not
quite the same as the sup--
so almost the same
as the supremum,
but not quite because I need
to ignore subsets of measure 0.
So I can write down a formal
definition in a second.
But I need to--
if I change W on the
subset of the measure 0,
I shouldn't change
any of these norms.
And so the one way to define
this essential supremum--
it's called an essential sup--
is that it is the largest--
so it is the smallest
lambda such that--
so the smallest number
m such that the measure
of the set taking value bigger
than m this set has measure 0.
So it's the threshold
above which you--
this, it has measure 0.
And the l2 norm will play a
particularly special role.
And for the l2
norm, you're really
in the Hilbert
space, in which case
we are going to
have inner products.
And we denote inner
products using the square--
using these brackets.
So everything is real.
I don't have to worry
about complex conjugates.
So comparing with the
discussion up there,
we see that a sequence of--
so sequence Gn of
quasirandom graphs
has a property that the
associated graphons converge
to p in the cut norm.
For quasirandom graphs,
there is no issue
having to do with permutations
because the target is
invariant upon permutations.
But if I give you
two different graphs,
then I need to think
about their permutations.
And to study
permutations of vertices,
the right way to do
this is to consider
measure-preserving
transformations.
So we say that phi from the
interval to the interval
is measure-preserving
because first of all,
it has to be a measurable map.
And everything I'm going to
talk about are measurable.
So sometimes I will
even omit mentioning it.
So it is measure-preserving
if, for all measurable subsets
A of this interval, one
has that the pullback of A
has the same
measure as A itself.
Let me give you an example.
So you have to be also slightly
careful with this definition
if you think about the
pushforward that's false.
It has to be the pullback.
So for example, the
map which sends--
so an easy example, the map
which sends x to x plus 1/2--
so think about a
circle as your space.
And here I am just rotating the
circle by one-half rotation.
So it's obviously
measure-preserving.
I am not changing any measures.
Slightly more
interesting example,
quite a bit more interesting
example is setting x to 2x.
This is also measure-preserving.
And you might be
puzzled for a second why
it's measure-preserving because
it sounds like it's dilating
everything by a factor of 2.
But if you look at the
definition-- and so here
is again mod 1.
If you look at the
definition, if you look at,
let's say, a subset
A, which is--
so what should I think?
For example, so if that is my
A, so what's the inverse of A?
So it's this set.
So the measure is preserved
upon this pullback.
And so if you
pushforward, then you
might dilate by a factor of 2.
But when you pullback, the
measure gets preserved.
So these measure-preserving
transformations
are going to play role of
permutations of vertices.
So it turns out that these
things are actually-- they
are quite subtle technically.
And I am going to,
as much as I can,
ignore some of the measure
theoretic technicalities.
But they are quite subtle.
So for example, so
now let me give you
a definition for the distance
between two graphons.
I write, starting with a
symmetric measurable function
W, so I write W superscript phi
to denote the function obtained
as follows.
So I think of this as relabeling
the vertices of a graph.
And now I define this distance.
So this is going to be called
the cut distance between two
symmetric measurable
functions, U and W,
to be the infimum over all
measure-preserving bijections.
So this is the definition
for the distance
between two graphons.
To take the optimal--
and my question does it--
I am looking at nth.
So I haven't told
you yet whether you
can take a single one.
And it turns out
that's a subtle issue.
And generally it doesn't exist.
But I look over all
measure-preserving bijections
phi.
And I look at the
distance between W and Wv,
optimized over the best possible
measure-preserving bijection.
So this nth is really an nth.
It's not always obtained.
And actually, this example
here is a great example for--
you can create an example for
why nth is not always obtained
from the discussion over here.
For example, if U is
the function x times y,
this is a graphon
xy and W is Uv,
where v is the map distance
x to 2x, then in your mind,
you should think of these two
as really the same graphons.
You are applying the
measure-preserving
transformation.
It's like doing a permutation.
But because phi
is not bijective,
you cannot putting phi here
to get these two things to be
the same.
So there are some subtleties.
So this is really
an example just
to highlight there's
some subtleties here,
which I am going to try to
ignore as much as possible.
But I will always give
you correct definitions.
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So can we expect the
cut distance between these two
sets to be 0 [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the
question, do we
expect the cut distance
between these two to be 0?
And the answer is yes.
So we do expect them to be 0.
And they are 0.
They are equal to 0.
And let me just tell you
one something that is new.
And this is one of
those statements
that has a lot of measure
theoretic technicalities.
For all graphons U and W, it
turns out that there exist
measure-preserving maps--
so not necessarily bijections,
but measure-preserving maps
from 0, 1 interval to itself,
such that the distance between
U and W, the cut distance,
is obtained by the cut norm
difference between--
the difference between
U phi and W psi.
So don't worry about it.
So far, we have defined
this notion of a cut
distance between two graphons.
But now I'll give
you two graphs.
So what do you do
for two graphs?
Or I can-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: You can take
the graphon associated it.
YUFEI ZHAO: Great.
So take the graphon
associated with these graphs
and consider their cut distance.
So for graphs G and G
prime, and potentially even
a different number
of vertices, I
can define the distance, the
cut distance between these two
graphs to be the distance
between the associated
graphons.
And similarly, if I have
a graph and a graphon,
I can also compare
their distance.
So what does this actually mean?
So if I give you
two graphs, even
with the same
number of vertices,
it's not quite the same thing
as a permutation of vertices.
It's a bit more subtle.
Now why is it more subtle than
just permuting the vertices?
So here we are using
measure-preserving
transformations, which doesn't
see your atomic vertices.
So we might split
up your vertices.
So you might take a
vertex and chop it in half
and send one half
somewhere and another half
somewhere else
because these guys,
they don't care about
your vertices anymore.
So it's not quite the same
as permuting vertices.
But it's some kind of--
so you allow some kind of
splitting and rearrangement
and overlays.
So you can write
out this distance
in this format, find out the
best way to split and overlay
and to rearrange that way.
But it's much cleaner to
define it in terms of graphons.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this why we
take bijections up there
[INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: The question is,
is that why we take bijections
up there?
And no, so up there,
if I wrote instead
measure-preserving maps, it's
still a correct definition
and it's the same definition.
And the fact that these
two are equivalent
goes to some measure
theory, which I will not--
do not want to indulge yo Great.
But the moral of the story
is you take two graphons
and rearrange the vertices
in some way, in the best way,
overlay them on top of each
other and take the difference
and look at the cut norm.
And so that's the distance.
So I want to finish by
stating the main theorems
that form graph limit theory.
And these address the
questions I mentioned right
before the break.
So do there exist limits?
And do these two
different notions of one
having to do with
distance and another
homomorphism densities,
how do they relate
to each other?
Are they consistent?
So the first theorem,
Theorem 1, has
to do with the equivalence
of the convergence,
namely, that if you have a
sequence of graphs or graphons,
the sequence is convergent
in the sense, up there, if
and only if they are
convergent in the sense
of-- in this metric space.
So remember what convergence
means in the metric space
is that of a Cauchy sequence--
so if and only if it is a
Cauchy sequence with respect
to this cut distance.
So it's just-- maybe
for many of you,
it's been a while
since you took 18-100.
So let remind you a Cauchy
sequence, in this case,
it means that, if I look at the
distance between two graphs,
if I look far enough
out, then I can
contain the rest of the sequence
in an arbitrarily small ball.
So the sup positive
m of this guy here,
goes to 0 as n goes to infinity.
But because we don't know
yet whether the limit exists,
so I can't talk about them
getting closer and closer
to a limit.
But they mutually get
closer to each other.
So Theorem 1 tells us that
these two notions, one having
to do with homomorphism
densities, is consistent
and in fact equivalent
to the appropriate notion
in the metric space.
So let's use a symbol.
So we say that G sub n
converges to W, or in the case
of a sequence of graphons.
So we can do that as well.
So here we say that G
sub n converges with W,
if whenever you look at
the F density in G sub n,
this sequence converges to the
corresponding f density in W
for every f, and
similarly, if you have
a graphon instead of a graph.
So that definition was
just whether a sequence
is convergent.
Here it converges
to this graphon W.
And the question is, if you
give me a convergent sequence,
is there a limit?
Does it converge to some limit?
And the answer is yes.
And that's the
second theorem, which
tells us the existence of a
limit, of the limit object.
So the statement is that
every convergent sequence
of graph or graphons
has a limit graphon.
So now I want you to imagine
this space of graphons.
So we'll have this space
containing all the graphons.
And let me denote this
space by this curly W0.
So this, the 0 is--
don't worry about it.
It's more just convention.
But let me also put a tilde on
top for the following reason.
Let this be the space of
graphons where we identify
graphons with distance 0.
So then the space combined with
this metric is a metric space.
It is the space of graphons.
And so the third
theorem is that it's
the compactness of
the space of graphons,
namely, that this
space is compact.
Because we're in
the metric space,
compactness in the usual
sense of every open cover has
a finite subcover is equivalent
to the slightly more intuitive
notion of sequential
compactness--
every sequence has a
convergent subsequence.
And then it's also,
if you have a limit,
so it converges to some limit.
So how should you
think of Theorem 3?
So it's about compactness
and some tautological notion.
But intuitively, you
should think of compactness
as saying--
and the English word,
the English meaning
of the word compact is small.
You should think of this
space as being quite small,
which is rather
counterintuitive because we're
looking at the space of
graphons, certainly at least as
large as the space of graphs,
but really all functions
from the square to the interval.
This seems like a
pretty large space.
But this theorem here says
that, in fact, that space
is quite small.
And where have we also seen
that philosophy before?
So in Szemeredi's
Graph Regularity Lemma,
the underlying
philosophy there is
that, even though the
possibilities, the space
of possibilities for
graph is quite large,
once you apply Szemeredi's
Regularity Lemma,
and once you are OK with
some epsilon approximations,
there is only a
small description,
this bounded
description, of a graph.
And you can work with
that description.
And these two philosophies,
it's no coincidence
that they are consistent
with each other
because we will use Szemeredi's
Regularity Lemma to prove
this compactness.
In fact, we will use a
slightly weaker version
of Szemeredi's Regularity
Lemma to prove compactness.
And then you will see
that, from the compactness,
one can use properties
of the compactness
to boost to a stronger
version of regularity.
But the underlying
philosophy here
is that this compactness is
in some sense a quantity.
It's a qualitative
reformulation,
analytic reformulation of
Szemeredi's Graph Regularity
Lemma.
OK, so--
So this topic,
this graph limits,
which we'll explore for
the next few lecturers,
including giving a proof of all
three of these main theorems,
nicely encapsulates the past
couple of topics we have done.
So on one hand, Szemeredi's
Regularity Lemma,
or some version of
that, will be used
in proving the existence of the
limit and also the compactness.
And also it's philosophically
and in some sense
related and very much
equivalent in some sense
and related to these notions.
It is also related
to quasirandomness--
in particular,
quasirandom graphs
that we did a few lectures ago,
where in quasirandom graphs,
we are really looking
at the constant graphon
in this language.
And now we expand our horizons.
And instead of just looking
at the constant graphon,
we can now consider
arbitrary graphons.
They are also this model
for a very large graph.
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can we prove the
theorem analytically and then
deduce the Regularity
Lemma with it?
YUFEI ZHAO: The
question is, can we
prove Theorem 3 analytically
and deduce the Regularity Lemma?
So you will see once
you see the proof.
It depends on what you mean.
But roughly, the answer is yes.
But there's a very
important caveat.
It's that, because we
are using compactness,
any argument
involving compactness
gives no quantitative bounds.
So you will have a proof of
the Szemeredi Regularity Lemma
that tells you there is
a bound for each epsilon.
But it doesn't tell
you what the bound is.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
Theorem 3 imply Theorem 1
because of the [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: Does Code
Theorem 3 imply Theorem 1?
And the answer is no
because in Theorem 1,
the notion of convergence is
about homomorphism densities.
So Theorem 1 is about
these two different notions
of convergence and that they
are equivalent to each other.
Theorem 3 is just
about the metric.
It's about the cut metric.
And so Theorem 1 is-- the point
of Theorem 1 is that you have
these two--
you have these two
notions of convergence,
one having to do with subgraph
densities and the other
having to do with
a cut distance.
And in fact, they are
equivalent notions.
So all great questions--
any others?
AUDIENCE: And for
that F, is F a graphon
because the [INAUDIBLE]?
Is F a graphon or a graph?
YUFEI ZHAO: The question is,
is F a graph or a graphon?
F is always a graph.
So in t F, W, I do not define
this quantity for graphon F.
So this quantity
here, I have only
allowed the second
argument to be a graphon.
The first argument is not
allowed to be a graphon.
It doesn't make sense.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't Theorem 1
and 2 together imply Theorem 3?
YUFEI ZHAO: The question is,
doesn't Theorem 1 and Theorem 2
together imply Theorem 3?
So first of all,
Theorem 1 is really--
it's not about compactness.
So it's really about
the equivalence
of two different
notions of convergence.
It's like you have
two different metrics.
I am showing that
these two metrics
are equivalent to each other.
Theorem 2 and Theorem 3 are
quite intimately related.
So Theorem 2 is about--
Theorem 2, so they
are quite related.
But they're not quite the same.
So let me just give you
the real line analogy,
going back to what we
said in the beginning.
So Theorem 2 is kind of like
saying that the real numbers is
complete.
Every convergent
sequence has a limit,
whereas Theorem 3
is more than that.
It's also bounded in some sense.
But here, there is
no notion of bounded.
It's compact.
But the main-- you
should think of these two
are very much related
to each other.
But here it's-- but
they are not equivalent.
Anything else?
Great.
So that's all for today.